what's up guys michael here the saying
geek culture as pop culture has become a
cliche and with good reason superheroes
rule the box office video games bring in
more money than movies and all the cool
kids play tabletop rpgs it seems the
mainstream has shaken off its affected
smirk and dived full force into
unabashed nerdum what's more the ways we
interact with pop culture have also
changed reflecting the behaviors of geek
culture that normies once shunned we
used to make fun of trekkies and comic
book fans were roasted for obsessing
over the finer details of continuity now
you can't even watch a movie where cars
go vroom without taking on a laundry
list of prior movies and spin-offs
wanting to play video games for a living
was once equivalent to wanting to be a
power ranger now esports stars make a
good chunk of what professional athletes
make without the concussions and going
to bat for your favorite franchise is
now standard practice i want to talk
about starcraft 2 in many ways the last
hurrah of the single-player rts and if
you ask me the rightful queen of the
genre so how did geek culture become
ubiquitous and does geek culture
actually still exist once it's so
mainstream get yourself comfy for this
wisecrack edition is geek culture dead
since the beginning geek subculture was
concerned with and unified primarily by
media especially genre fiction which
means the geek culture has been
inextricably tied to the concept of
fandom important note geek culture
overlaps with fan culture but doesn't
encompass all fandom basically all geeks
are fans but not all fans are geeks
anyway modern fandom has really been
around since the 1890s when sherlock
holmes captivated the emerging urban
middle class holmes fans even protested
when sir arthur conan doyle killed off
the beloved detective so much so that
the author begrudgingly brought him back
to life while the term fandom was
applied to sports and feeder lovers
throughout the 19th century sci-fi
literature lovers appropriated it as
they developed much of the fannish
infrastructure jargon and language still
used to this day according to scholar
francesca kappa sci-fi fans started
communicating via the letters column of
famed magazine amazing stories soon they
began to produce their own zines
was this geeky behavior for sure but
according to scholar lars konzak geekdom
as we know it today can really be
credited to the culture built by world
war ii veterans especially engineers and
intelligence officers when veterans
returned from war and began their gi
bill funded higher education they had
the time and space to process what
they'd been through as konzak explains
they expressed their reaction to their
unique experience by creating and
embracing science fiction novels
superhero comic books and military
strategy board games this konzak says
coalesced into its own distinctive
alternative intellectual milieu around
the cold war era but modern geeky fandom
was poised to really explode around 1966
when scifi made the jump from books and
movies to the more accessible tv format
and fans of star trek arguably set the
blueprint for geek fandom as we know it
today belittled by the mainstream they
formed a subculture of their own to
express their passion born in part out
of the counterculture movements of the
1960s trekkies were super grassroots and
self-organized they created a dedicated
convention popularized fanfic and
cosplay and some argue got their show a
third season as technology progressed
creators could bring ever more
engrossing worlds to life and then of
course star wars hit in 77 and
spearheaded the now ubiquitous approach
to merchandise by now a fandom had
attracted scholarly attention akademik's
initial reactions to fandom stereotyped
these new fans much like they had sports
fans as being pathological it was even
commonly suggested that fans needed
psychiatric help but that didn't stop by
the 1990s dedicated fandoms had become
pretty commonplace for geeky fiction all
following the grassroots subculture
example set by trekkies the growth of
the internet facilitated greater
connection between fans than the readers
of amazing stories could have ever
imagined by this point it was possible
for people that have been in a fandom
for most of their lives and it was
around this time that fan studies
scholars started pushing back against
prevailing stereotypes most notably
there was henry jenkins an academic and
fellow fan frustrated with the
mainstream stereotype of fandoms as
mindless and anti-social consumers
obsessed with immature stories jenkins
explored fandoms ethnographically he
framed them as communities rooted in
creative engagement with a given media
text creating new meanings to base the
social actions of the subculture key to
this is a conflicting set of emotions
to jenkins fandom is both fascinated
with and frustrated by the media they
focus on they're emotionally invested in
the world of the text but that
investment also breeds frustration with
the text inevitable shortcomings this
fuels acts of creation like fan fiction
and art also known as fan labor through
acts of fan labor fandoms are
essentially tailoring the text to
reflect their own tastes views and
experiences although it's not just
creative interpretation it even extends
to acts of evangelism like when fandoms
organize enmas to save their favorite
shows jenkins labels this participatory
culture where the public has more agency
in the formation and definition of their
culture participatory culture acts as a
sort of grassroots counterpoint to
mindless media consumption but even as
smart folks started defending fans of
geek culture one thing remained the same
the mainstream's scorn according to
scholar dan hassler forest fans had
mainly been perceived by hollywood film
studios as irritants niche groups of
excessively invested consumers whose
limited numbers rendered their voices
insignificant films like tim burton's
1989 film batman were thus purposely
tailored to attract the largest
mainstream audience rather than to pay
homage to fans according to hasler
forest that was about to change with one
big ass franchise lord of the rings
director peter jackson sadly embraced
the simmering fan anticipation for the
film he gave the blogger behind fan
website the one ring a private tour of
the set let her take photographs and
eventually relied on her as a main
source of publicity for the sequels this
marked what hassler forest calls a
shifting relationship between fan
culture and media industries where fans
were addressed not only as the ideal
consumers of a commercial fantastic
franchise but also as valuable
contributors to the process
the commercial success of lord of the
rings fans started being viewed as
influencers who could produce hype that
would ideally bring in an even larger
audience this potential mushroomed as
the internet expanded in media
industries started to rely more and more
on networked cultures and spreadable
media according to hassler forest what's
more performing fannish behavior has
become less taboo which hassler forest
argues is in part due to the radical
individualization that marks our social
media environment as a result a lot more
people are doing fandom and there's
every reason to think fans will continue
to become more important as hollywood
keeps chasing the most profitable ip
some scholars think phantom will become
so mainstream as to render the
distinction between fan and average
audience member virtually insignificant
now mainstream media didn't start
embracing fandom out of the goodness of
their hearts stats show that the most
dedicated fans of tv and movies spend
around 45 more than the rest for gamers
it's
230 percent what's more fans vastly
outnumber casual viewers couple that
with fans zealous dedication to hyping
their favorite franchises and you can
see why no red-blooded exec could
possibly keep ignoring them over the
years geek fandoms have proven to be a
valuable commodity to media corporations
which has meant a fundamental shift in
how fandoms form corporations are now
actively looking to create fandoms from
day one with different tactics for
different stages of fandom all to stir
fans into the most passionate and
profitable state at the same time geek
culture is becoming increasingly
corporatized conventions like new york
comic con and chicago comic and
entertainment expo and so on are being
bought up by read pop a subsidiary of
global events organizer reed exhibitions
which continues to engulf ever more once
grassroots events at the same time film
studios and media conglomerates have
increasingly infiltrated these events
luring fans with exciting exclusive
previews that they'll be sure to tweet
about and now media corporations have
found ways to commodify fandom itself by
exploiting fan labor this takes myriad
forms like competitions where the prize
is your fan art being used as
promotional material or being featured
in the movie that's also known as unpaid
labor or leveraging ip law against free
fan works like short films or game mods
only to release their own versions soon
after even fanfic is being exploited
take shipping the practice of creating
fanfic around theoretical romantic
pairings in an ip historically a way for
queer fans to create their own
representation popular ships are now
being incorporated into marketing and
even alluded to in the text themselves
just to get fans in the door
but often it's a trick these ships are
largely ignored in favor of straight
romances this isn't necessarily the end
of the world but the iron grip
corporations are starting to have on
fandoms arguably creates problems when a
corporation all but controls a
subculture can you really call it a
subculture anymore and what happens when
a subculture used to operate in his
outcast in opposition to the mainstream
finds their forum confined by corporate
oversight similarly subcultures like
those surrounding indie rock punk and
emo music have encountered these same
tensions essentially fandoms used to
play in the woods but corporations have
paved them over with a high fenced
jungle gym the question then poses
itself when fandom is mainstream does it
even really exist anymore fans may be
courted by corporations but do they
actually have power especially when a
few media conglomerates own almost all
of popular culture's ip it depends who
you ask
from jenkins interpretation fandom could
be seen as an active way to invert the
increased consolidation of ip he argued
that fanfic in particular is a way of
the culture repairing the damage done in
a system where contemporary myths are
owned by corporations instead of owned
by the folk this interpretation sees
fans as active creators and consumers of
their favorite geek media rather than
passive receptacles for whatever
corporate media wants them to stand this
is interesting because jenkins
acknowledges that the media that fandoms
form around are essentially corporate
products regardless of the empowering
aspects of jenkins proposed
participatory culture fandoms are still
emotionally invested in something that
corporations make for profit which is
why others argue that the fan autonomy
celebrated by jenkins is something of an
illusion some of this has to do with the
power of the mighty ip as simone murray
puts it the ultimate discretion of media
conglomerates to shut down fan creations
around corporate owned properties
renders hollow much cultural studies
champion of fans contrarian impulse that
is to say when disney by the way of
marvel can sue you for using too many
clips in your reaction video to ant-man
can you actually take culture into your
own hands according to hessler forest
not really he argues that there's a
grossly asymmetrical relationship
between fans and media producers such
that fan autonomy becomes somewhat
illusory he writes that when beloved
stories become highly profitable global
entertainment brands they no longer make
up a form of cultural commons that can
be appropriated embellished transformed
or subverted instead they become
lucrative corporate franchises made up
of a wide range of commodities most of
which are dependent upon fans to achieve
their desired commercial value that is
to say media producers have both the
power to stop fans from circulating
their arts and their resources to
produce a gobsmacking amount of content
and products in both limiting fan
production and aggressively encouraging
fan consumption media producers are
arguably co-opting fan culture while
stymying its expression what this
argument really spotlights is the
tension between the two sides of fandom
fans as anti-commercial subcultures
organized on a grassroots level and fans
as rabid consumers and promoters of
corporate ip and as fandom becomes
increasingly mainstream that tension
might just constitute one of the most
important debates about how we consume
media
but what do you guys think has corporate
involvement changed what it means to be
a fan is there still room for geek
culture let us know in the comments big
thanks to our patrons for all your
support and don't forget to check out
our podcast shove that subscribe button
like it's a nerdith or locker and don't
forget to ring that bell and as always
thanks for watching later
[Music]
you